hey guys I'm so excited for this video
because as a lot of you know I've always
wanted to be able to fly a drone now
I've been so inspired by so many people
who have made such amazing drone videos
and the only thing that I've ever really
wanted to do was be able to fly one if
you've been following me for a while you
know I have tried in the past and I have
failed but I have been super determined
that I will be able to do this so I
recently got one I'm going to be able to
fly this drone before I learn to fly the
drone I had to get the drone and I have
to unbox the drone so I'm pretty
confident that with some proper training
and some proper instructions I'm gonna
do a really great job and I am gonna be
putting myself through flight school
helping you instructions read and
understand the user manual okay this is
something I might actually read the
weekend oh this is so much excitement
alright what do we have about a charger
I probably should you got another
charger because I have an extra battery
some accessories well alright
hmmm this is the professional ones of it
is a 4k camera do you hear might be
important
here's our controller dude this is weird
Wow Wow Wow let me look at you
look listen okay everything's charging
up probably put this thing together
shortly Oh someone's here at the drone
mascot look at you Maddy I'm trying to
set this thing up for at least four
hours but somebody keeps eating all the
parts so I am now with the drone expert
yo would you like to introduce yourself
to my friends I might and match to the
coolest little 360 spin that you totally
just miss as a call what's so cute about
cutest dog ever and way smaller than you
think
yeah he's really so today we're gonna
set this up and we're gonna do a little
test and see if I can figure out how to
flattest do you think I'm gonna be able
to do it well find out we will beginner
motor maybe we'll try something fun we
can do this all right so our first test
we're gonna set this thing up and yeah
it says please match them
watch this okay you go okay
I think I can handle this I got four
backward left right so I should do
default then we'll just definitely do
the call continue okay does she like to
invert controls my boys do not like
invert control how are we doing none of
that so you want to see two buttons with
these guys but there's more yeah
so in case the camera gets a at a spot
you can click the button Jill hmm right
forward so that way if you lose focus
for your at you hop back on all right
guys so this is the day I have been
waiting for so long to officially fly
the drone I've been practicing in my
house which is completely different from
the outdoors
let go
so awesome
thank you guys for watching I hope that
you enjoyed this video I have been
wanting to fly drone for I don't even
know how long ever since people started
actually flying then I've had my few
fails in the past I've always been so
inspired by it'll be amazing drone shots
people were able to capture it and I was
like I want to do that I just I want to
be able to get those shots too and guess
what I have and I have succeeded and now
that means that a lot of you guys will
be seeing a lot more drone footage here
on my channel so thank you to everyone
who has inspired me to actually overtake
my fear and make this challenge actually
happen cuz guess what
actually she can